derrière la question de l'état de droit
il y a en réalité et moi je suis obligé
de le constater au parlement européen un
procès politique continuelle qui est
instruit à sens unique contre ces deux
pays en particulier est souvent
d'ailleurs sur la base d'informations
qui sont absolument fausses on a parlé
là tout récemment d'indépendance de la
justice
on a entendu beaucoup de choses sur la
pologne la hongrie dont bien des
accusations se sont avérés être en
réalité complètement inexacte
pendant la crise du coronavirus par
exemple vous avez peut-être pu le lire y
compris dans des médias français on a
expliqué que viktor orban n'avais
quasiment aboli la démocratie en hongrie
et que par exemple il avait suspendu le
parlement hongrois
ça a été publiées dans des médias
français dans des titres de presse qui
ont pignon sur rue et c'était une
information qui était pourtant
totalement inexact le parlement hongrois
a siégé continuellement pendant la crise
du coronavirus et elle est le et le et
la loi d'état d'urgence qui avait été
votée en hongrie qui avait suscité tant
de débats étant d' alerte a été abrogée
avant même que l'état d'urgence
sanitaire ne soit abrogée en france donc
il ya là évidemment j'allais dire un
procès qui ne me paraît pas être de
bonne foi qui ne me paraît pas être
équitable et qui va toujours dans le
même sens et je m'étonne d'ailleurs
qu'on ne parle jamais quand on parle
l'état de droit de la situation chez le
gouvernement socialiste maltais à malte
une journaliste a été assassiné pour
avoir mené une enquête sur des faits de
corruption impliquant le gouvernement
je m'étonne qu'on ne parle pas du
premier ministre tchèque monsieur
babiche qui a détourné 13 millions
d'euros de la politique agricole commune
pour une exploitation appartenant à sa
famille et qui a menacé de mort des
députés européens du ppe qui voulait
faire une enquête parlementaire sur ce
sujet là et là pour le coup pas
d'article cède pas de discussion sur
l'état de droit
là pour le coup aucun sujet n'a paraît
en réalité d'où vient cette crispation
elle vient de la question migratoire de
la crise de 2015 avec le désaccord fort
qui a été exprimé par viktor orban sur
la politique migratoire à l'époque
emmenés par angela merkel avec une
fracture très forte au sein de l'europe
et aussi au sein il faut bien le
reconnaître de notre famille politique
et puis elle vient de la politique
sociale de ce conservatisme qu'on
reproche aujourd'hui à la pologne et à
la hongrie
[Musique]